you know how i've been using this phrase
this is not a rehearsal
this is the real thing and i've used it
so much in a sense that it's become a
meme
well it's also beautifully accurate to
describe what it is that is going on
right now in all aspects in the lead up
to this november of 2020 election
our suspicions about the improper
purging of voter rolls
in georgia have been confirmed as
we have now received news that
yes the state of georgia removed
nearly 200 000 people
from the voter rolls by wrongly
concluding
that they either moved and didn't jump
update their voter registration or for
other reasons
no longer needed to be on the active
voter list this is exactly what we
believed was going on
in georgia this is exactly what we
believe is now going on
in wisconsin pennsylvania notice these
are all important states it's not
happening in
idaho which is going to go to trump for
sure it's not happening in massachusetts
which is going to go to biden for sure
at least not to this degree
the aclu of georgia put out a report
about this
and it has indeed concluded
that this purge was
not proper and it was a way to just pull
people off of the voter rolls now the
georgia secretary of state has said that
the removals were no such purge
everything is fine this was just
routine maintenance on voting lists and
what they claim they did
was simply remove inactive voters
because this is a provision that the
state has
where on some period some rolling basis
they go through and apply a logic for
what is now an inactive voter now what
deemed someone an inactive voter
if they hadn't voted for three years
i'm sorry if they had not voted in two
general elections
and haven't had contact with the board
of elections
during that time and if that
situation lasted for at least
three years that is a very low bar
to deem someone as inactive two election
cycles where you might not vote
really is not a sign that you should be
removed from the voter rolls this is
really the wrong conversation because in
many countries this entire concept
of being registered to vote is a lunatic
concept
registered to vote you're a citizen
and you can vote and you don't need any
pre-registration this is not a
restaurant reservation where listen not
everybody goes to eat at a restaurant
so if you want a table you've got to
call ahead this is voting my friends
and about 313 000 voters in total were
removed that's about four percent of the
voters in georgia
and um before uh
at at some interim period 22 000
were re-added to the voter rolls through
december of 2021 because of a lawsuit
but again this is just a fraction of the
total voters that are removed now you
might also remember that brian kemp
was secretary of state of georgia when
this was done
and he was also running for governor
which he ultimately won
by only 54 000 votes against stacey
abrams
so you don't have to look too far to
find red flags in this election the guy
saying we should pull hundreds of
thousands of people off of the voter
rules
not only was the guy running the
election but he was one of the people
running in the election so do not be
surprised when this happens
again across the country in november
and i wish i had some grand solution to
this well we're gonna
aclu is gonna take aclu is going to try
other voting groups are going to try
greg palast is working on this issue
but at this point we've got eight weeks
to go we we have
it is september 3rd the election is on
november 3rd that's what 61 days
i think 30 in december i'm sorry 30 in
september
gets us to october 3rd and then 31 in
october gets us to november i think it's
61 days
we need to outnumber them in extreme
numbers check if you are registered to
vote
figure out where you vote find out if
there's early voting
figure out how to request an absentee
ballot so we're in the description
to this youtube clip we have resources
at usa.gov for confirming your voter
registration status
with links to how to register if you
have not yet done so
the deadlines in some states are coming
up and then we have
vote.org polling place locator
and absentee ballot request these are
central websites usa.gov and vote.org
which will direct you to how to obtain
the information you need
in your particular state they're doing
it
it's been confirmed that they've been
doing it they are going to do it
and later today this is unbelievable
donald trump has now suggested that
voters commit the felony
of willingly trying to vote twice to
test
the system i'll talk to you about that
later but chaos
is the word that summarizes all of this
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video